ser cierta esta información qué
beneficio le reportaría a Cuba tener
esta base
Yo diría que Cuba Ya básicamente tomando
una decisión que Su futuro por el
momento
está mucho más alineado con la de China
que con la de Estados Unidos sabemos que
aquí hubo una apertura bajo la
administración de Obama pero ya eso
parece que está muy muy atrás muy muy
lejos en la memoria y este los chinos
están siguiendo lo que antes tenían bajo
la Guerra Fría una acercamiento a China
hablando de guerra fría cree que estamos
en un escenario geopolítico que podría
digamos caracterizarse con estos
términos
Yo diría que sí actualmente y es mucho
más complejo antes la Guerra Fría era
esencialmente entre Estados Unidos y sus
aliados el otan y muchos otros contra la
unión soviética china en en esa época
estoy hablando de los años a partir de
los fines de los cuarenta cincuenta
sesenta china no tenía el poder militar
económico que tiene hoy en día así que
ahí está la diferencia que tenemos ahora
este conflicto de la Guerra Fría nueva
pero que está liderado por un lado de
las partes autoritarias por China y por
los otros y por el otro lado Estados
Unidos Ha sido tanto ahora podríamos
vincularlo también un poco a la cuestión
interna cubana no me refiero a lo
siguiente La Isla atraviesa una dura
crisis económica no y según lo
trascendido el acuerdo para la base
sería de miles de millones de dólares no
podría ser esto una forma de obtener
ingresos para paliar la crisis para Cuba
sin duda de que la parte económica es un
factor importante para los cubanos al
fin del día si los Estados Unidos fuera
no sé pero ahí está el tema que es una
parte económica y también el deseo de de
China y de Cuba de mantener un gobierno
que no es democrático que es muy
autoritario así que ahí entonces aunque
puede ser que económicamente le no sea
tan beneficioso para Cuba tener a China
pero políticamente sí esa combinación
económica y política si les va a hacer
algo atractivo
hablemos ahora de los intereses de China
no porque hay varios análisis e
hipótesis al respecto asistimos a
momentos de tensiones no entre Estados
Unidos y China por Taiwán en caso de ser
ciertas toda esta información podría ser
una cierta estrategia de la nación
asiática vinculada a este conflicto
Yo diría que durante toda la durante la
mayoría de la historia civilizada del
mundo los chinos Siempre han mostrado
una una cultura y una tendencia para
planificar estrategias a largo plazo
Estados Unidos como sabemos aquí por
razones de elecciones que tenemos cada
dos años
cambia y y mantenemos como una
estrategia pero no al nivel que tiene
China Ellos están aquí jugando un juego
que que está mirando 2030 40 años hacia
el futuro esto comenzó en serio en hace
diez años con con este la iniciativa de
los chinos del cinturón y la ruta que
comenzó en el 2013 los chinos están por
todas partes del mundo están en muchas
partes de América Latina y eso es parte
de su estrategia
al nivel geopolítico